is there something to be said
about the the flip side of that which is
um
when you're training with people at the
same skill level
being okay losing to them yes you have
to see
training for what it is training is
about skill development
not about winning or losing you've got
to you've got to understand
that you don't need to win every battle
you only need to win the battles that
count and the
the battles that count are in the world
championship finals okay
that's the one that counts think about
that win
okay that's the one you're going to be
remembered for you're not going to be
remembered for the battle you lost on
tuesday afternoon at 3 p.m in some
nameless gym with some guys that
no one cares about no one's going to
remember that you're going to be
remembered for your peak performances
not your everyday performances focus
your everyday performances on skill
development
so that your peak performances you can
focus on winning
you know i just this is not a therapy
session
but if i could just speak
every session is a therapy session
there is still an ape thing in there
of course you think i don't feel it you
think
everyone in the room doesn't feel it
because for example you haven't never
seen me roll
uh you know when there's people you know
i've seen the look in people's eyes when
they see me
train and they i could see maybe it's me
projecting but they
think i thought you were supposed to be
good i thought you're supposed to be a
black belt
like that look they're like stuff i'm
gonna give you some therapy
okay
do you know how many people have come up
to me
over the years who have visited
the training halls that i work in and
they come up to me and go man
i rolled with gary tonan i did really
well with him
like like really well really well i'm
like oh that's very very good very
impressive
and then i see them talking to their
friends like man
i tapped out gary toner
and i'm i'm sitting there going
yeah and you can see that they're just
like wow dude i'm i'm
way better than i thought i was gary
tonin
all of my students um i pushed him in
the direction of of
giving up bad positions so that they
practice working getting out of critical
situations is a huge part of our
training program
but gary tonan takes that to a level
that just no one else
even gets close it's it's just amazing
like he will put himself
in impossible situations where
it's a fully locked strangle
a hundred percent on with both his arms
behind his back
and he'll try to work out from there
yeah and
seven times out of ten he does but three
times out of ten he gets caught
he i'm a huge advocate of handicapped
training
where you handicap yourself to work on
skills
he's took that to heart to a level that
few people i believe can match i just
wonder what his psychology is like
because
it goes back to what we talked about
four legs you have to understand
its skill development don't take it
personally um
i understand i hear where you're coming
from we've all got what you called the
ape
reflex where we want to be dominant okay
we all do like
because there's thousands of white belts
out there that have tabbed gary tonin
yeah and they're walking around and
they're people saying online i tap gary
tonen
like gary tonan's like one of the best
in the world so i'm one of the best in
the world
and um uh does gary get upset about this
no of course not because gary knows that
when it counts on stage he's going to be
going 100
with a set of skills that very few
people can match
um he can go into an ebi overtime
at the 205 pound weight division against
an adcc champion
starting in a full arm lock position and
effortlessly get out
with no problems in seconds because he's
been in that situation
25 000 times with varying degrees of
skilled opponents and there's just no
panic
no fear he's just doing what he's done
so many thousands of times and
that's a fine fine example of a guy who
didn't give a damn what happened in the
training room
but when it counted on the stage in
front of the cameras
it it kicked in
you